hello whoa that's not us that that's not
us at all hi I'm Joey everyone hey I'm
Sam and you can tell this stream has
definitely thrown together a little bit
late that's fine okay hey everybody
welcome Monster Hunter Monday's we're
playing Monster Hunter heck yeah
on a Monday we're gonna be over to your
stream here so hey guys we're playing
we're gonna be fighting the elder dragon
the Elder Dragons today so yeah we're
gonna fight all three of the late game
Elder Dragons after you fight New Yorker
got a so we got a stream ID so you can
go ahead and join us if you want to play
with us if you're able to or also just
something I was happening last week when
we were playing people just joining in
this yeah just a good time we didn't
come hang out on a monster or two
regardless of skill level join in and
hang out stay a while and listen alright
I think that worked we were having
issues with me connecting you I think I
think that worked I think we I think we
got it now though hi radio looking good
sunny looking good as well it's
fantastic to see you all here on a
Monday I feel good now I was like stress
and there's so many things I couldn't
even tell you we're stressing too cool
under pressure
I'll thank you but yeah we're gonna
we're gonna get everything started here
practicing my sumo for fighting those
those other dragons that we're gonna be
fighting so we've got some real mene
mene boys on the on the menu today a
goopy dragon an angry lion and what was
the other one oh a steely dragon Steely
Dragon Ball Dragon so this is on the
PlayStation 4 so if you have a
PlayStation 4 copy that that code should
work for you unfortunately we can't
cross hunt which would have been really
rad so excited to have this game I'm
excited for you to have this excited for
Monster Hunter cross hunt
yeah well I mean they already had Master
Hunter cross then double cross came out
and they didn't localize it and we're
all really upset about it monster head
cross play the mantra cross play exactly
an Xbox X crossed with a ps4 logo
because
we want to have friends hanging out for
F [ __ ] that's pretty good so let's see
here you're gonna you're actually the
one who's on the quest strike yeah I'm
just filling up on my Bally's it's
making sure we got everything all
together I've I've already got my my
business sorted I'm trying to figure out
if I should use my switch axe or my my
long sword though actually say I finally
built the the long sword that I was
looking for see here loaded up we're
good change equipment quest challenge
one yeah we there we could do that it'll
be a nice way to warm up it's not an
elder dragon but it's going to do we
want to start with I'm down to give it a
go okay oh yeah I'll even do my I'll do
my long sword because I just got it now
and got a chance to try it out yet okay
and we could we could check that out
what's up Bob Jones hey Bob see
philadelphi won the Super Bowl last
night is true shoutouts to those bird
boys they took that ball and they ran it
to their side I sure beat those Patriots
was my favorite Metal Gear quote damn
the Patriots man so want to see those
guns I've been trying to build some
really cool guns for you guys but I'ma
be honest what do I got here I got I got
a bow that is still my big Dumbo I've
got just joined our session that's
that's our call from last time from last
time yes these are our professional
carriers coming in to save the day thank
you sir
I really wish the boy this gun wasn't
called a jaggers cannon because that
just sounds real dirty and I gotta cross
blitz oh well we'll mess with some some
guns later on oh well let's do a warm-up
we'll start with the that the cool event
quests West that just popped up that's a
good way to do it I don't I don't think
it's gonna be like high rank or anything
but it'll be a fun thing to see like how
much we've progressed you know how far
we've come
where is it I think it's cool
Yakub with that what is y'all gonna make
me lose my mind then maybe it hmm that's
pretty easy it's flush flush carved from
bone looks like it's gonna be a rough
time but it's not even high rank 6 you
want to do that one it's it's the little
dudes let's do it you know it's the only
high rank event quest let's just do that
let's just do a quest just get me warmed
up here yeah yeah we you got it you got
to get situated you go together I got
three vouchers ready so I'm gonna pop oh
oh nice when we fight them no our boy
tenacious is in as well real good in
that spikey near you got a armor rockin
some high-level stuff yeah I'm I'm
seeing if the set is good I don't know
yeah it looks cool it's ostentatious as
hell but I'm way into it up here with
this quick little easy event quest and
then we're gonna get right into Dragons
hardcore dragon let some people get in
here and again if you want to join it's
right this this number right right down
here you can you can join in on our game
help us carry us hang out with you we
got the old we got the old crew back
together wow look a bunch of people are
join I love it and again if you have a
question gotta do just post it up I'm
sure people in the game will come and
help you it'll be a good time we could
all hunt together and create a better
monster hunting world for all of our
pals cities going crazy waiting from the
land Oh God I imagine I've been hearing
some crazy things about posts big game
events we have see tenacious still
getting getting together yeah give him a
minute it's all good oh yeah so uh what
what do i what we do after this what's
like the
Oh gonna be our plan funny you should
ask if you're curious what you're gonna
be doing in the end game in monster
honor I recommend checking out this
video that that is on gamespot.com
called what what to look forward to in
the Monster Hunter n game paired it's
voiced by a very sexy Oh it's true at
all a very a very handsome boy
well if monster hunter on Mondays
continues to - all right and they decide
to keep us around yeah we'll probably
hunt some of those what are they the the
purple variant angrier versions I forget
what their colleagues temper temper
temper some temporary probably do some
event quests we got lucky today because
in the in the meeting today they were
like we if we put up any gameplay of
just the the three elder dragons we're
like oh oh we got one offered here it
comes
your Mondays coming at ya so yeah we're
gonna be I know exactly where these
things are this is gonna be a real quick
quest this is yeah this is gonna be
pretty easy telling it like it is
we just like to sit back and watch other
people do everything for us it's true my
entire 130 hours have been playing this
game has just been sitting the whole
time I'm really good at it
I'm actually pretty excited about so
well I definitely want to hunt with our
with our boys that we got back but if
they're I want to make sure to check the
chat and check the player list and see
if there's anyone else oh yeah wants to
join in because I want to give I want to
give other people a chance as well and
this uh this longsword hits a lot harder
than all the other long swords I've had
that's exciting so I like for the like
middle tier hours of my times like the
the 60 to like 80 I completely stopped
using my long sword that I always use
cuz like in all the monster hunters
before I had used it basically the whole
time and I became a switch axe switch
axe boy cool but oh yeah we're
definitely have to fight deviljho
for sure oh and that comes out the angry
pickle boy absolutely so look forward to
that maybe little bit if they kick us
off the air
least be able to be like a we got this
new monster we need to fight we need we
need to go fight it you get the crew
together and and go hit them up alright
where we yet we got they should be up
here actually I think and in this area
too this is good I just needed like a
moment thing to kind of like so to
breathe in and reassess get everything
ready you've been sitting on these
quests all weekend yeah you got to them
on on Friday and then we're like oh
let's save it for the stream we'll save
it for the stream so this will be my
first time fighting these boys which
will be a good time I think should be
good I mean it's my first time fighting
near gurgaon say last week yeah and we
pulled that one out I don't know how it
was intense I cried a little bit
afterwards but everything's okay and I
forgot to how to end the stream huh
she's completely flabbergasted so yeah
oh man Red Dead Redemption will
annihilate all these games sales-wise
you know probably I guess and that's
okay I'm alright with that it's a it's a
good game a good time hey man about the
money it's true there you go the monster
hunter Monday important lesson for the
day don't do a capitalism although if
you were to look at Monster Hunter as a
series it's very explicitly about the
capitalism it's not a great game to set
as an example by we take from that and
we learn exactly should count like one
more of these dudes to kill this is this
is the perfect uneventful quests we're a
little I feel like way over geared for
this but yeah that's okay oh look we get
more people in perfect I love it
see this is the point where I think a
lot of people are starting to get into
like the higher rank now they're they're
kind of people have caught up to us
model here sweet we did it yowsa
that was a spicy chop
that sure wasn't it was an easy quest
I'm real glad that we were all here for
this we all showed up in our top two
your gear okay so we're gonna we're
gonna head back gonna make sure we have
the right I'm full up on potions all
that good style your delicious nutrients
who are we gonna fight first I figured
we'd go an order the order it's listed
so I think we're starting with a steel
boy steel boy oh man ancient forest
that's gonna be us gonna be a fun time
oh he's not in the ancient forest oh
because that's where the that's where
like the tracks were so the tracks were
there but you end up or at least I ended
up fighting him in the others recess oh
okay well I'm sure that's probably where
it is too then yeah that's just kind of
I think I assumed it would be there
there we go
look at that synchronized and you got
the eyepatch - oh it's so good he's the
least amount on my head but oddly enough
has the most amount of armor we got some
bandages I don't even know what those do
resistance Jul good good fantastic good
stuff
waitis specialize in those tools yeah
so how how was everyone's weekend how
how did you do how many monsters did you
hunt did you manage to do some monster
hunting with all the exciting sports
activities that went down how are you
it's been a while it's been a week I
want to catch up with you again yeah
you've been doing good how was your
weekend it was great I played Yakuza
kiwami heck yeah scan your and you're
you're telling me you're you're so
excited about it you're heading straight
into the second straighten it - we're
not even waiting for Kwame - now do you
that's gonna take forever that's never
come they haven't even in now exactly
this is what you do you learn Japanese
and you import it and then you do it do
it that way that'll definitely be faster
definitely um I need I even use anything
why am I look
in my item box there's nothing for me to
like clean up okay let's see here
did I get my internet fixed missed oh
yeah yeah actually it took a little
while but I finally have actual Internet
guys so I don't have to sit there and
just watch anime and play my offline
games which is kind of cool but I ended
up just watching anime and playing my
offline games anyway during the weekends
so that was the thing yeah
be the best spider-man we ever played as
long as they have the pizza-delivery
missions that's all so I want out of the
new spider-man with the music and
everything the music has to be there
it's very important but yeah all right
all right hook us up uh we might have to
switch to your your feed for the start
of it but right we can do that here I
want to make this a really seamless
transition I'm gonna be talking to the
person and you're gonna be talking to
the person and it's just gonna switch
ooh just like that it's like nothing
even happened the the seamless pass off
dang okay so cool now we're going to
post a new class I was right in the
camera I was doing it I was right there
I live in Philadelphia so you know how
my weekend was you know it was probably
wild sounds like a good time I believe I
just when you see a cutscene so you guys
might have to yes we might have to hold
up before we jump in oh it's okay it's
it's got a load in all that dragon it's
a lot of dragon oh no that's okay just
was posted up it happened last time yeah
and it works yeah I just posted it again
and it was fine
what graphics setting are you playing on
so I think you have prioritize frame
riot eyes frame rate I'm playing on a
pro so good it's a good call
ah I'm playing on a regular ps4 so I
don't have options for that post it up
post it up post it up come on don't do
this to me saving Dana
Rinne again let's see if I can join now
but I doubt I know it's this party of
one
dang doesn't even give the option well
so let's check my equipment here yeah
I'm gonna have to have to wait okay okay
there restock I'm gonna eat my food now
so I'm ready when you you find them
they're very easy to find which is
fortunate I want to see some Oscar on a
world PC at max settings me to my dude
great I I'm fairly certain I'm gonna
double dip my cool drink in there he's
definitely gonna double dip let's see
we're on top of the world right now oh
man it it sounds like a good time when
in winning that big game alright let's
make me some mega potions some good
crafting could wholesome crafting I like
it well as people we got hanging out
here this is great I love it I'm gonna
accept some of my uh my guild card
requests wom in here because I totally
forget to do that sometimes and you
can't do it when you leave I make I
can't make an ancient potion that sucks
I'm also gonna send mine out to everyone
you get a card you get a card everybody
gets a card no I hate that I like craft
but it goes to my I wish I could just
craft it directly into my item pouch
come on
there we go okay all right see some food
whoa look at all these people all right
where we got a regular regular hangout
happening all right guys so I'm going to
head on in we're gonna see the cutscene
and then hopefully you boys can join in
on me yeah it's gonna be a heck of a
thing I'm excited this this one actually
gave me a bit of trouble when I was
fighting it myself
yeah you were I remember walking by and
all I just it just looked bad there's
it's it's real windy time I had to build
some specialized armor at one point on
quest away we go but I mean you go will
go eventually would you say it Monster
Hunter is hard solo I'd say that it's
challenging but not super challenging
like obviously the oh you got dropped
right in the lava like the elder dragon
fights are bigger and they're more
intense but I mean it's it's nothing
that is insurmountable it's got a good
feeling okay just finding those those
cool cool buttons let's see here all
right so I actually think they are I
think they're up by the right after the
second set me straight by the way nice
character Oh Pablo likes your character
well thank you I'm actually I'm kind of
jealous because like everyone else in
the office made a female character and I
was like oh maybe I'll do that and then
I started to think about it I'm like no
know if I should cuz then we can we
cover both armor sets and all that stuff
oh I'll tell you right now it's not
gonna end well
that's great yeah this is good this is
perfect it's a real it's a real scary
boy
and see you're out there ready to join
oh you know it I'm so jealous how the
armor that that set just looks so much
better on you than it did on me I like
it quite a bit it's it's real good okay
oh wait live updates - that's real good
oh that's nice you know actually popping
out of the way yeah okay this guy some
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna jump in it
and tell you how everything everything
goes bright yeah I feel like you'll
you'll probably get a good good rank on
that work sometimes it doesn't do my
jump attack I just like fall off I don't
know why do you need to have like your
full demon meter for now you just gotta
have it up and you have to have at least
a decent Mouse down mouse just doesn't
do it I'm not really sure not I'm not
too keen on on dual blades myself but I
I was looking up some stuff this weekend
and they've got a lot of really cool
things so I might build more into into
the dual setup you're in I'm in I'm on
my way
saying someone's Granberry saying this
is the most annoying of all the other
dragons yeah I'm not a big fan of them
is a real not fun time especially
towards the end like when he goes back
up to his hiding area yeah you have a
lot of one shots not necessarily out of
one shots it's just again he hasn't done
it yet but you'll you'll see like his
his thing oh come on down that's
understandable she got this though we
got this
[Music]
we got room for one more I think we've
got a second one on the way
earth fourth one on the way I mean heyy
where you going where you flying don't
come at me please
boy I just realized you've been you've
been playing like this the whole time
having you I mean or like you you hear
the other other sound oh yeah yeah
you've been hearing my song the whole
time I just fainted
it's okay it's alright it's this is this
is a real real elder dragon stuff right
now this is intense
[Applause]
yeah I've got I got way more defense
than the last
oh shoot
oh snap I didn't grab cuz I didn't get
dropped off at one of the areas okay so
the good thing about this fight that I
was able to kind of help cheese it with
is that you do start out right there
very close to a a room that he gonna get
supplies from
and Connie in the back
I could make the jump I was wrong
Mon dude switch X is real good it's a
lot of fun
we got tenacious in sweet now it's a
party
captioner started killing it so you
can't and Captur Elder Dragons it's a
it's a do or die kill or be killed kind
of situation
yes I land on okay i him but I didn't
actually like
any hits are good it's just the heads
so those those tornadoes are the things
that are are the worst and not even like
busy they do like damage or anything
because they just they make your
character gets stun for so long eat it
eat it so so much
it's moving
you feelin it yeah
nope that wind okay you're right that is
it's on real real frustrating I still
think that even after this fight like
it's it's kind of downhill like the
other two are more manageable than him
all right
do you swooped on you it's okay so all
good well if we die we'll just have to
yeah that's probably the thing that's
realistically gonna happen here because
these guys are not jokes voices a bit
lower the the game sounds a bit high
well we'll just whoo I hear myself a
little hop out and get into my my weird
asthma voice which I definitely won't do
bring him a little bit closer to this
edge that's what we need how's he doing
he's still pretty healthy let's throw it
throwing wind everywhere oh my goodness
oh geez surprise he's here he did the
wind thing on me as I was jumping down
Oh naughty table oh yes there we go out
looks very good get the tail
oh cool we got founded ah excellent this
is exactly what we need tea market it
makes the dreamwork
or so I'm told nah dude this game is
great I highly recommend it if it looks
cool to you you're probably gonna have a
good time because it is knocking down
try to flash prod him down I would but
we've got someone on him yeah they can
knock him down there we go I'm totally
gonna whip every single one of my hits
right now
I didn't want to do that anyway I was
just testing him yikes
there I'll just jump up in the air and
get him to also I didn't bring any flash
pods because I'm I'm not a prepared
hunter I do have nutrients in prepared
I didn't start bringing nutrients until
I started fighting these guys cuz
there's almost a given that I would die
looks like we got some drops yeah no
sweet at least I got a material oh he's
running away even if we lose I got a
thing all right
take this head over that way
yeah right now I'm at a point where I'm
just like out of a lot of material so I
need to start like farming more material
yo if they put in a t-rex in here again
I'd be way into that I want the gormogon
to come back in DLC he might be one of
my favorite monster boys which is weird
because he's a newer one but I like I
like them a fair amount try and do some
no or you could just hitting me or Tori
could just dive bomb on you just dive
bomb through the wall that's cool I love
it and reach that one over there Oh God
uh hello
I just want to knock the ceiling down on
them yeah you were talking about no I'm
so close he's not having any version
Hannigan's
youch pick up some of this it was a
crystal burst over here I need something
that too kind of shooting them all
moving around there we go what
no it makes wagons depends how precious
one of the best names yeah I think my
favorite online name I've ever seen is a
weed Lord Vegeta that's pretty good it's
pretty good
men tale I'm trying to think of one that
I really liked when I was a kid knows
playing Halo 2 the one that kind of got
me was someone had made their xbox live
gamertag in obese Toyota that's so like
although weird death messages like when
you run someone over would say you were
splattered by an obese Toyota it made me
giggle
every time I think about it and I'll
never forget it we had someone we would
we would do that on like custom games we
named them dumb stuff like that so we
did like a parked car I like it you've
been run over by a parked car sniped by
a parked car those those are the those
are the good times gonna someone explain
this game to me kill monsters here or do
you hunt them and make them yours so you
can hunt them to kill them to get parts
from them or depending on if they're
another dragon you can't capture them
but you can capture all the other ones
and if you capture them it gives you a
chance at better parts than you can use
to make better gear Yeah right so the
entire game loop is basically go out
hunt monster get parts for monster make
pants for monster use those new pants to
fight the more difficult monster that
you then build pants off of to fight
another
I don't know if that fully explains kind
of what it is but that's a really simple
boiled down right in the face it's okay
that's the first try third time's the
charm
you got me we'll bring up all those
deaths for mine I apologize it's it's
okay it's your first time fighting him
it's your first time it took me at least
three or four times okay
I'm this guy specifically a little
better exactly Oh yours in that flash
flight cage that was a hard thing for me
to say for a second I should probably
switch that actually all right you think
G rank will come out yeah I think
eventually I feel like it's kind of
silly like they don't have it in already
but once they do imagine the imagine the
ridiculous amount of time you're gonna
be spending on top of what you've
already spent ah which is kind of crazy
there's an achievement for getting to
rank 100 Yeah right pretty nuts I'm
gonna do it how much more do you need a
play to get to that I more I need to
play more hockey oh my god are you at
right now I'm only like 29 because I
haven't been able to fight any of the
the redone monsters I can temper there
you go I keep forgetting what they're
called okay I'm going to set up some get
some equipment here I grab some flash
pods and do I have and I should be able
to join you this time because you've
already seen the cutscene yes you guys
should just be able to join me right
away now which is good yeah okay what do
you need to make don't worry he's strong
even for veterans in the series you did
well for a first time see there you go
thank you
it's bitter bug and blue mushroom it's a
it's a difficult fight okay to be quite
honest boys another try and if that
fails we'll move on to the next dragon
yeah and then we'll keep going and we
can come back just to make sure that
everything is buried up we'll do maximum
three three tries and then we'll move on
to the next one that sounds pretty good
okay
oh yeah there's no PvP in this
game but yeah say blue mushroom so
that's that's the interesting thing that
you bring up most games get their G rank
in the ultimate versions the time that
it's gonna take for the PC version to
come out a lot there are a lot of people
who are kind of speculating that it will
be like the ultimate version of the game
will have G rank included like right off
the bat for PC players that makes sense
yeah I'd be I'd be into that see I might
change too yeah yeah all right I don't
know why I'm why I'm trying to fight it
I must i'ma switch ax boy and I know it
don't expect that to be free DLC they're
in charge for it because a lot of extra
work one of the new monsters it's true
it's kind of crazy how much they're
already giving to us for free I think
especially with them having to redo a
lot of whatever they're adding in yeah
absolutely
always wondered what G&G rank stands for
God rank might make sense I'm actually
not sure I just kind of accepted it in
we got going on here there there people
people doing the optional optional
fights for it up on the up on the board
people are it's pretty red dragons yeah
yeah oh heck yeah good awesome awesome
get those tracking fly people are
participating and doing stuff all right
I still have any nutrients I can
probably kind of buy nutrients I don't
think so
man let's check maybe actually because
you can buy potions and stuff yeah let's
see if I can just buy some that'd be
preferable oh I want to build I want to
build this armor that you got Draven I
like that well that's cool-looking it's
from a tiara I believe but I'm really
into like because all the stuff that you
make from them is kind of like like
Knight armor looking stuff and I I kind
of really like the knight armor looking
stuff okay so now you unfortunately
cannot make nutrients which sucks just
go start putting them in the inside of
that cultivation Center I have
cultivates them and those going which is
good other than that I should be okay so
yeah just get those go inside in just a
minute I get my meal on on hanging out
yeah hey know much I just defaults of
the chefs the chefs yeah
that's a good looking sword that's a
good looking armored yeah you got you
got everything that I'm looking for look
at that oh look like a badass yeah it
just looks like a Warcraft set so I'm
really into it requires a lot of stuff
to build you have to like farm different
monsters for each piece and then on top
of that you need elder dragon blood for
every piece so you got to form a bunch
of Elder Dragons and then you got to go
farm like every high ranked monster in
the eldest recess that's not an elder
dragon so requires a lot of
different parts to make that thing just
notice my monitor slightly in the shot
oh really
what monitor I don't know what you're
talking about
yikes I think I think we're okay alright
cool all right
whoof overall cheaper to make max
potions and pop one of those stocks true
you don't fight against you do but I'm
not going to because we're we're
fighting Elder Dragons and you can all
join I don't want to embarrass myself
trying to fight them again I've been
trying to fight them all weekend look at
that
chef cat I accept this yes finding waha
sock right now and getting murdered
straight murder dude that's I believe
that we'll be there in a moment it'll be
getting murdered in a moment - okay I've
got the same people from last time cool
let's see if we can make this happen
I like it I really like the music that's
in the gathering hub it's really nice
still preparing unfortunately
there we go ready for departure what
weapon do you recommend for new hunters
you can't go wrong with the sword and
shield
Sartain shield I'm sorry long sigh
really there are people who will argue
with me about long story but I feel like
the long sword is great for new people
you could probably get a good handle on
the switch axe if you want something
that kind of lets you mess around with a
whole bunch of different things the
range weapons work pretty well but bow
if you're able to wrap your mind around
the idea of like a Mo's and coatings and
stuff that might be the most difficult
part for it but can't go wrong with dual
blades yeah dual blades are also very
fun if you like the really fast-paced
action games that's a gimme for sure
yeah is there a game you SWAT squad we
can join I think so I don't know if we
have to be leaders to invite people to
it yeah I'm not I'm in some squads but
I'm not a leader I don't think I can
invite people I'm gonna wait he's right
here
oh boy yeah kind of oh yeah hammers are
also really good Justin use hammer
hammer because they they do a lot of
just stunning and they do a lot of
damage a little bit slower but they're
pretty good grim knows what they're
talking about
I got a better but that's what she
that's what you need to make those
delicious so nutrients nutrients yes I'm
just gonna collect them as we fight all
right we're done it yeah so we got dual
blades to switch axes and oh god and a
charge blade for our setup so this is
gonna be real good I like I like where
this is going
see if I can make this happen here just
wanna like they in a too far just just a
little bit too far I should use
so I finally switched my camera over and
it's the best decision I've ever made
oh the yeah I switch to the the
old-fashioned lock-on okay I need to try
that though
yowzer I'm just gonna sit here and
realize it's been a long time since I've
used my switch X somebody has commented
on how you look like sink oh yeah it was
there's a bit of an influence there for
sure so I'm glad that you you recognize
it
come on stay on the ground I can't hit
ya it's like us definitely on purpose
Brian's calling me out I do like Metal
Gear a lot so at this point I probably
just make characters look like Metal
Gear characters without even thinking
about it your your second character is
named Meryl I also am really bad at
coming up with names and Metal Gear
names are the first things that follow
minds fair Diamondhead some material did
drop
this never works out I don't know why I
tried to do it so Elder Dragons have a
really like they love knocking you off
whenever you try to do like special
moves okay and that's been a real hard
thing for me to make a tail whoa
yeah see like that just knocks me
straight off can't believe it
I feel like this is going much better
than before but I don't want to jinx it
yeah Sam and then the music for all
these are so good just get right up in
there yeah
oh it's windy in here close the window
oh I did not that was an accident but a
cool accident
you guys have flares helps take down say
no it's true I brought in flash pods
grinding some flash pods hi I gotta make
flashcards
oh those no worries got to equip them
but we've got it we've got it all set up
now we're with Gigi
Oh oh come on boy I don't know what just
happened but it all worked out in my
favor I was not gonna stop that was a
thing like I was like I was in the
middle of doing a combo then he like
rolled away and then he rolled back in
for the second hit like all at once nice
you know I don't know if I did that but
I'll take it
I do for the win if you guys if there's
a way to get rid of the wind there's
wind resistant stuff but it does it
didn't do much when I tried using it no
this whole whole area is kind of nice
it's really real close quarters he's a
big boy
I'm not I know I can't believe I
actually reached when I did that he's
out who's worth it for a greatsword with
big damage and negative 30% face so that
they kind of I don't want to say equal
each other out but like you can help you
build a certain way if you go one or the
other I for instance really like
affinity just because I like the crits
and all that but it it'll work out for
you
the the more damage definitely makes up
for that all right charge blaze are by
far the best weapons I have I'm still
not very good with them but I want to be
good with them yeah same so I'm I'm in
the continuing process of learning how
to play a charge blade man it's I I
don't have the the flow exactly down and
it's not it's not the best oh we got a
pal over here oh and smacked
yes yes yes awesome
yikes hey we do have pally right so over
there
I think he's supposed to be giving us
buffs just sin they're playing is his
instrument up on that rock
ouch so I'm the same way
grim I like doing the affinity affinity
bonuses Oh [ __ ] you get a roar like
me I was like about to do like my
special aerial attack just stop Joe just
just stuns ya midair like it just
doesn't make any sense
Clem oh nice nice nice
that was a nice hit
that that's that charge blade that's a
charge blade nonsense I love so much
someone got a charge boy here yeah don't
do what whatever we're doing this is a
bad place
oh my god okay okay all right I got a
heal we're good your boy almost got wind
tunnel combo'd
game looks awesome it is very cool I
like it a lot still gonna go off and say
I think this is my favorite Monster
Hunter I have a lot evil say that they'd
like since the beginning but the ones
that I played since try this is my
favorite one
gaijin hunters said this is like
probably the best monster I trust that
you Sicilian so there are two people I
go to for monster on her stuff
gaijin hunter and pro jared which is
he's not oh he's a pretty big monster
he's not top tier monster hunter but I
like him a lot and he also cries a lot
and they both start off their video
reviews saying that it's their favorite
Monster Hunter yeah so I was like oh I
guess my opinion lines up with the two
people that I value their opinion very
highly on this set
that might mean I'm on the right track
I'm into it but yeah so I was those kind
of cool
oh yeah
[Applause]
see that's that's the good hit up that's
what I want do it that's what I'm here
for my dude oh you saw that on your
screen what would have I was just trying
to hit a him and I whipped it's that's
that's cool sometimes right Oh roof you
know
come on almost there don't knock me off
stop it
Mon I believe
you know I like to do what I wanted to
do but he's down now so that's that's
pretty good
there's a lot of sounds going off oh
hello there just beat the game on Sunday
congratulations it's got to be a good
feeling
cuz I know how I felt when I finished it
oh no he's down shoot oh I can still do
that when he's down that's awesome
draven draven is hitting that that thing
up also I was falling down my screen oh
wow good boy my stuff oh I feel bad you
more messed up real bad I don't feel
good about this I got I got too excited
about washing my friends you know oh
he's almost gone
really his heartbeat sensor is real low
at least I can say that much okay got
some dragon pods I'm very surprised that
he's not going back to his house those
gonna get these footprints no sharpening
my stuff oh good call my things actually
still blue break the wings I'm trying
there they're very they're very hard
wings I feel like you can but no it's
sick huh yeah alright come on over this
way it's kind of his last area no this
is his last area is up on on top of the
thing oh come on oh okay yes I missed it
I missed I can't believe I missed it but
you can do it yeah that's cool so that's
that's good to know
he's inside of that that wind tunnel I'm
hitting him with the dragon pod I could
knock him down
nice oh that solves that so far away
Oh
alright guys stay cool and we can do
this it's it's in the bag it's in the
refrigerator there's a tail you got the
tail I don't know if I did books we got
we did as a team got the tail oh cool
I mean I was limping away he's gonna go
back oh yeah he's he's hurt guys I don't
want to tell car jump so jump the gun
for this might be it
mate with me about to finish already one
person down so we got it's this last
area that really throws everything off
well that's why I'm saying we gotta we
gotta be cautious yeah do have did we
had we had one cart so far right yeah
we've had one car okay that's good
that's I think this is I think this is
good
whoo okay hunter rank 59 at 160 hours
can't wait for G rank my dude same I
mean I'm not at 160 yet getting there
though
so hunter range is drastically jump
because I'm still only so 14 when you
finished the last monster hunt yeah in
the story they unlock how to rank and
basically any extra monsters you've been
fighting on the side like help bolster
that oh so like you're hunter rank 14
right now but now we've unlocked it and
you've jumped up to like hunter rank 30
oh okay that makes more sense cuz I was
just sitting there being like dude I've
been playing this game for like 70 hours
I'm only 14 like you expected me to get
to a hundred like what the heck yeah I
think when I finished the story that
jumped me up to 29 oh I did bring any
barrels with me I'm why I brought some
barrels oh don't worry
tenacious tenacious is on it I got two
large barrel bombs dude you got you got
those those bombs put those bombs down
those bad oh you just climb up the wall
oh you can just do that yeah it's it's a
weird weird one everyone brought bombs
but maybe I know someone got yours
don't wake Danny I didn't even know I'd
even gonna use mine alright well I'll
use him on the nice guy
there you go that's fine so hope you're
ready this is about to get real oh look
at all that wind everywhere I'm not
ready for this get back down here
this is the thing yeah right
oh I missed him we have any flashes I
have one I'm gonna wait until I know
he's up though oh I'm gonna not mess it
up too bad well done
oh man I'm frozen or having problems
with Nagi ghonte he's he's the first
like hard check I know no oh he's he's
not one to mess around with ah this is a
nightmare
yeah it's real windy we're going to do
this to be safe
I find you can kind of just like hide
underneath this rock though stand right
in front of me oh and then just
immediately right Zack big dumb face no
no no no no no game please don't
oh please game you're okay you got this
I got a max potion
I just got it and you just just gotta
stop being stunned okay I'm good the
wind yeah it's it's real bad
not no I'm gonna try to go up here
because he hasn't put anything down up
on in this area come on over pal
nope can't even I can't even get in your
room oh one more I hit him and he knocks
me back onto the thing dude where is he
I don't even see him he's down on the
left side when we came in okay oh no no
that's [ __ ]
I hit him with my aerial and then he
knocked me out of it
yeah it you know the wind like itself
doing like this done and all that
something like it also makes it real
difficult to find him
it does okay I got a jack
there's more wind just can't even see
him this is what being a blow person
would actually probably be pretty nice I
think I'm not sure so was it the the
first time I fought this guy I got him
here it was down to like 10 minutes I
spent 10 minutes just getting juggled by
the wind like I am now in almost killing
as I walked over to you guys and like
I'm on the straggle
he worked me that's where you're
referring to
yeah ah dude this is this is rough
I found your health thing I'm gonna sell
it okay cool I found him I just walk
around this wins me me okay did some
hits did some hits mega potion oh he's
down there he's back up he's up here
he's down he's down hit him hit him hit
him
[Music]
hey come back here dude dude dude no
dude don't run into that wall oh there
we go
whoo so what it does that it like
flickers for a second and you think that
you think of you die yeah I thought I'd
died it's because you're expecting to
die but we didn't die cuz we killed the
dragon today no we got two more of a gun
more to go Oh for an hour
yeah it's just the rest of the day and
we'll be able to finish the game right
I'll be great okay anything else to do
oh geez that's a lie I think so I think
tiara might be might be an easier one we
might I one-shot them by myself okay
cool
but that might have just been dumb luck
cuz music is very triumphant right very
happy with it whoo all right
dude I'm just we did it what's a crystal
burst I thought it was a part to pick up
I need to like we yeah supposed to feel
weaker and stronger than they used to be
stronger because they're everywhere in
prevent movement exactly it's it's a
heck of a thing I I get like that's the
whole point of the fight but man it
really messes with you but it's so fun
so it's just I'm just real a real sweaty
sweaty mess right now
[Music]
look at that where was I I didn't even
show up my goodness
driving Val more so all you gotta do is
just carry the the right stuff and I
think you're I think you're good to be
Val okay
what do we need no berries lots and lots
he had some blight no berries okay I
think I should have plenty but the fight
wasn't too bad no berries I assume cool
drink cool drinks cool drinks for cool
cool people here I'm still stuck on the
engineer story mission do that Anjanette
story mission also doesn't mess around
at the various probably the the game is
first like real big challenge which is
kind of funny looking back at it because
like it's it's a monster that definitely
like the telegraph what they do really
well like people who play a lot of
Monster Hunter or like Oh engine F I
know kind of exactly how this all works
but it's still like it's still is able
to mess you up
and that's the weird thing about it am I
gonna do here oh let's do this one we do
it more more looks at what the limited
bounties are nope that's seven rank
general seven rank got one one out of
the way
heck yeah yeah this is like a little
eight I believe there are also jewels
that you can kind of stack for it too
all right so we'll just make sure we
have the right equipment here where am I
on oh yeah I got mac snowberries we're
good oh we're not doing him first we're
doing a ostrich though I'm sorry yeah
right we're done to ask let me just
carry it anyway cuz you'll happen that's
that's fine um what I need for teh
oestrus fire resistance
oh I'm set then my arm does do my armor
resistance 22 fire resistance right
you're you're in a good place I should
I'm not gonna you know what I'm not
gonna switch my armor I'm gonna sit here
and hold out hope look at all these red
people we got in here I'm so into this
that's good I love that any time I would
like real talk if I could if we get
stream monster hunter anytime and just
have a bunch of people hanging out like
doing hunts and doing cool stuff like
that that's that'd be cool
more than anything be real rad have all
three other dragons unlocked who should
i do first so the way I did it was
reverse order
I went from the from the bottom up I'd
say do the one we just did because it's
probably the hardest a lot of people
seem to kind of feel that way but okay
you're you can't you can't you can't do
it wrong going anyway but I feel like
fighting that steel dragon dude is
probably the best way to to start off
there's a fire resistance
Arshin knows what armor is that this is
the what is it even called what am I
even doing something crazy hot whoa
none of you guys are here this is you
know the session I don't think you got
kicked out cuz you're still here maybe
you just have to load in there we go
oh you're all popping in okay cool it's
cuz you're on that that's sweet ps4 pro
you just leave it here and just look at
all these cool people all the time this
is great oh yeah they're all up there
all popping it now
Oh should we make a squad that's just
for Monster Hunter Mondays a monster
monday squad do you do it I I kind of do
let's do it
did you get it you're gonna make it
right now I'm into it right now I'm I
like this creative squad critten emblem
I don't even know that what what emblem
encapsulate s' 101 days is all about the
backpack cuz we're getting carried all
the time there you go nailed it I love
it and we'll make it a nice orange no
delicious I like orange that's a good
color and it's also a good a good delish
some precious fruit because we love you
oh this is it's beautiful it's more
beautiful than I thought it would ever
be perfect
see then like Nova was saying that that
one was particularly easy for them to
it's go for whatever one you think will
give you cooler armor let's see if I can
turn and stick with that one thought T
Oscar was the hardest see it's it's all
over the place right I've created the
squad
hit me up with that invite I don't give
me out of this like what James GameSpot
everyone you're all invited hekia
received an invite to Monster Hunter
moment everyone here into this for sure
hekia take me take me in their joint
squad Monster Hunter Monday's processing
that squad information we did it
can the xeno jiva be color changed so if
you know I'm gonna try to point at my
screening that's gonna make it really
weird because you can't see what I'm
doing but if you look actually making
just do a clock like the the in-between
of the armor that you can kind of see is
like a black color his stomach all of
that that's the stuff that can be
changed so I just changed all the black
everybody here they're all they've all
been officially invited I like if this
is Monday's this is the most successful
spot I've been a part of how many
members are you a lot of having a squad
I don't know you want to find out just
find out keep adding people every time
we do a monster hunter Mondays
everyone's everyone's welcome here I
like the heart with the backpack a lot
I'm just getting a bunch of
notifications like that's that's real
good alright alright so this is one
where you're gonna have to probably hold
on you want to do a switch again switch
again I'm gonna I'm gonna open up the
book and then we're gonna do the switch
over you're good it's like nothing even
happened whoa
alright we're on my thing now let's do
it alright once again I'm gonna try the
back here again this time hopefully will
oh yeah you see it on the first try you
can't change the color of the
the wings on the armor unfortunately I
really thought you could I wish you
could but okay so once again I'm gonna
throw you guys to join cuz we're gonna
see the cutscene cutscenes look at that
cat thanks hi I'm here it's a
good-looking meal you have I'm the
person who listened been stomach just
eating all the food like a tapeworm
these live shows are too late using a
toothpick to open your eyes it's oh
shoot dude I'm real sorry I didn't man
if I could stream all day to make it
easier for people to watch I would yeah
where do you live yeah that's a good
question it's currently uh noon for us
oh you're gonna get the you're gonna get
to him real quick he's literally right
through that doorway oh cool oh there's
a door well take it take a sip on that
cool drink oh yeah that's a good call
see what do we got here should fill this
up man I didn't even know there was a
door over here nice I think it's just
gets made for this but yeah
oh damn
[Music]
you ever like the monster hunters like
step into a room like that and be like
man I messed up I shouldn't be here this
is I'm not allowed to be here
okay why am i stunned already welcome to
the jam it's teh Oscar time
alright let's do it I already ate
oh I guess I shouldn't have gone over
there we were all posted up just waiting
ah perfect I love it I love it you guys
are the best
we're ready to do this this okay I'm
feeling him out feeling out his moves
lion dragon scorpion of right murder
whoo-hoo see an SOS flare in a lava cave
that's a good question
unfortunately with the other dragons I
mean the SOS take so long to shoot out
right yeah this one looks angry
in particular I also really like how
they have like really blue eyes and
everything around them is red yeah it's
really rad it's a good look it's a cool
looking monster alright so got that I
got that this is a rat arena to fight
him into yeah yeah alright so I'm a bit
away I'm on my way back all right I'm
going to drink my cool drink so I'm just
ready right away
all right we got a whole whole squad
here Oh V Phoenix is bringing in that uh
like great sword technology nice I like
it okay
a drunk scorpion dragon I mean weirder
things have happened so hard the final
boss is you were saying they're not as
hard as oh the the last boss yes so the
last boss is very intimidating but once
you kind of like it's really easy to
kind of tell what they're doing
I after like maybe two times fighting
them I knew every move of their doing
and I knew exactly how to counter
everything but it's still a very good
fight just not as challenging as you
might hope how much room for aerials
here I think there's one area off to the
left it's like a couple lips you can
kind of maybe pull some stuff on though
all those little fire clouds are the
worst yeah oh it's real hot over here
what I found the lava I wasn't even near
it I don't even know how that happened
so the real rad thing about this armor
even though it doesn't have like great
fire resistance is I'm immune to
catching on fire oh that's pretty cool
so it's like a weird trade-off so I
thought I'd give it a go
oh yeah if we all hang out over here
maybe he'll just come over this way it
worked yeah youch
yeah
I got a real good real good whack on his
tail there
okay I feel like I feel like this is
going well too but I also don't want to
jinx this yeah I didn't want to say
anything I was thinking that else
already I'm on a space I got hit with
some fire
what dude how did that even happen was
that like an AoE thing I think okay I
should keep an eye so he has a big air
we move where he blows up surprise cool
I totally forgot about that until the
moment where I got knocked back and I'm
like oh god I'm not gonna say you jinxed
it Ben ah yeah yeah maybe just a little
bit he's running away though that's good
okay I'm gonna get my stamina back still
don't have enough no Barry or better
bugs actually I can meet him craft one
oh no I never mind you need like 10
bitter bites yet so it's a thing but
totally worth it oh I found him hello
there
he's over there now it's good good to
see you again my school is that other
arena yeah you know actually let me
switch back to you whoo sounds good
I'm into it
yeah yeah got some some expert strategy
have chatted up yeah so the the horns
we're talking about how to not get got
yeah
my favorite part about master honor
fights is knowing not how did you got my
tune was a good flash that's made out of
like a what's the call battle laggy on
oh my Fionna of course a torch brought
against the fire guy would not do
anything
yeah watching nice always the second
strike
I figure the batter's know
good good papi
or get up on there under at all this is
bad this is real bad I need out of here
this is not what I need to do yeah he's
on fire he's I think he's close to
starting to get ready to do settling for
that which I did not last time I think
the big towel is actually your camera
pulls back when he starts to do it oh
dude it's a good axe I'm sorry for
looking at your axe
oh that's it he's doing it no no all
right one more okay
he won't explode anymore it's just two
times all right well there's that free
meal pocking I love it so the only
explodes white no I'm I'm just saying
that kind of like oh okay I thought
you're being serious I was like oh
that's pretty nice well he's he's 200
gonna explode again Joe it's very much
that suicide bomb think of the near you
got a switch axe I haven't made it so I
ain't got a chance to use it very much
The New Yorker got a dual blades I got
are pretty good yeah uh I hate that I
want to like make all the different
variants of weapons and not like make
other weapon types so I've got like
three different long blades right now
there we go before he runs away to get
that mount real quick
yikes I should've paid more attention my
boy who's gonna fly away with me see you
later get that discharged i'ma fall
right down into it youch the head
and
every swing of your weapon speaks of who
you are thank you make the swings count
one thing that remains oh there is a
chainsaw you can get dual dual chainsaws
wait yeah there's a dual blades it's
just chainsaws
oh man I want that so that's a thing
what tier do I need to go down for that
one I actually don't think it's one of
the higher tier ones oh yeah all right
okay can try and do some some fancy
fancy footwork he's gonna just kind of
explode I feel it he's got fire all
around him yeah that's nothing gonna
happen man running away no she's getting
a running start for his fire breath nice
whoever did that well played killin it I
got I got there just in time to feel I
can either run away yeah real nervous
right now
get that tail yeah I'm backing up
it's got a real good taillight going on
whoa good seen him for to be honest it's
gotta happen soon everyone's just kind
of like giving him space yeah everyone
no one wants to be near him though I'm
down with staying away like let this boy
blow off the steam then we'll come back
in and finish the job
don't run towards me stay away from me
[Music]
come on do it just do it man just if to
hit him a certain amount for him to do
it I don't think so I might I might jump
in I think I can take them I think I can
take the hit from it I'm gonna hit him
I think we might have to be hitting them
a bit more yeah I think so no we don't
work that's good that's real good yeah
they go away no
Austin's done he's on fire
oh no no no no no no no no no shoot did
you got you got it you're good good for
me he's going right for me he keeps
going after me
he knows he's like this guy needs this
quests he's the one don't do this to me
man run away it's the most volatile
bombs the most intense boss fight ever
we're just waiting for you knock that
down by hitting it with a pod
oh just fell on him how'd you do that I
don't know it just happened
yes always living away we only got the
one
told you he only blows up twice oh shoot
oh that's something he'll get out of
here I'd like him to leave no stay away
from me please
Oh get out who leave he knows what's
good for him he'll better head back to
his fire cave Oh smooth be really good
that was bad timing on my part [ __ ] that
up okay I'm gonna go tickle on his tail
real quick yes like yeah we'll grab this
tail good work you're just gonna crush
the tail real quick you ready for that
drop
on here it comes
any second still happening I'm just
gonna carve up mine there we go
yeah okay I know is good I like this
guy's this is all according to plan boy
get back that car guess who didn't bring
bombs this time - I brought bomb it's
your boy - large
I only trust two things my my left fist
in my right fist I hope I don't use bomb
awful really I kind of like the general
look of tails armor it kind of falls
apart in the like the hips and the legs
okay now everyone kind of tiptoe
you know just okay look all back to the
Canseco I'm just a bigger bomb we got
some big bombs
yeah
oh look at all that damage look at all
that damage look at all that damage whoo
that was awesome
we did it what's river is dry uh two
down one to go
I was really nervous we're gonna make
that one my feelings on them I feel
pretty good this one I got my voucher so
I'm gonna get some extra extra goodies
my shoutouts to Kerry and V Phoenix for
again carrying us yeah - good - good
excellent let's get like a like a post
raid picture with the down boss oh yeah
like that no post up yeah action poses I
love it
yeah yeah I got that classic boss that
throwback laughs one the dark souls of
Monster Hunter bosses to deal with get
the blood borne the blood borne the
monster under boss I hate I hate that
I'm not I'm doing it as a joke I swear
guys I swear the slinger sniper that's
also what they called me in high school
on the board for that one I feel really
bad I might have gotten too excited at
the end of that kill and I'm worried
that I might have disturbed people
outside it's right it's Val time
get yourself a snack pull up the seat
get ready buckle up it's time to go no
berries on no berries every every day
exactly looks like it's taken from from
blood-borne or something the boss itself
looks like it's from blood-borne yeah
it's definitely it's a really rad boss I
liked him a lot
not as much as I love my Oda Garen loved
that boy too much he's real good and
grabbed all my stuff here you're doing a
good job but you need to kill more
though pretty much go out and kill more
for me
guys who tell me how cool awesome hunt
thank you that was I was real fun good
one
all right all right and you've got
you've got a post up the quest when you
can will join in
so he's guys I'm gonna go pet the poopy
for you got a pet the pooper good luck I
realized I haven't been doing that this
whole time I call I should probably go
back and do that to do it without the
music that's a bold move that's a spice
move John Luke what do you mean I can't
believe what I just saw with my own eyes
I was able to do that I'm gonna go do it
with the sound and mess it up real quick
I just I'm not good all right don't [ __ ]
this thing else you go that's totally
understandable thank you for hanging out
as long as you did and hope to see you
next week
back on Monster Hunter Mondays take it
easy but for the rest of us we're gonna
fight this spooky spooky dragon with
real angry mouths really like the stream
guys Thank You Malcolm I'm glad you're
enjoying yourself
awesome oh it's great here I'm anytime
someone comes in and they're able to say
hey this has been a good time I feel
like we've we've done our job
I found it working come here Keith
I named my book to my Pugi Keith I like
it because he looks like a Keith now
it's a real monster hunt okay
oh this is fun I'm glad it's like
sometimes I'm hearing myself yeah and
through the through the microphone Oh
which I'm totally into I mean someone's
got very like to me I like I like to
remind myself of what I sound like
because hello cyborg man it's good to
see you welcome we're about to fight a
ball huzzah
one of the Elder Dragons in Monster
Hunter world and I hope that you are as
excited as we are
it is John there's first time fighting
him so it's gonna be a good a good deal
we've got good we've got a room up we've
got our pals in here hanging out
drinking and causing a ruckus quickly do
some stuff
do those things I'm gonna get my food
really quick so that I'm just ready when
you're when you get loaded in delicious
but on that redbull cuz it gives you
wings you know it got speaking of I
don't know if I've did I tell you about
my theory about the energy drink and
battlegrounds no you remember how they
had to change the can design yes cuz it
before it said hot bull and it looked
like a Red Bull can but I didn't realize
like I literally realized that the day
before they changed it over
what hot bull meant because it is an
item that gives you a heal over time
which is called the hot in like an MMO
so I thought that was really clever and
I kind of got upset that it took me that
long to figure
oh I like that huh and now it's gone
which is really sad they take it out
because it's too close to being a Red
Bull type of thing just finish the game
now to see what hunter rank you are let
me know dark lord I want to know I want
know where it puts you also
congratulations here we are yeah hold on
I'm gonna I'm gonna bring it in hit that
hit that switch it don't even don't even
notice it it's like it's it's a
completely different situation okay all
right and I'm going to wait till you
post that up and then I'm gonna sit here
and I'm gonna wait for you to find them
so if you actually took the other camp
even you find them real quicker or well
my bad it's all good
yeah you're right I totally know where
to go but this this is all your your
actual first this is genuine your
genuine first experience you're picking
the the first area hmm so they'll do the
reason I know where to go is because
when I was exploring finding the tracks
I found this like area at the bottom
that had like what was clearly a door mm
fleshy door and I was like that's that's
definitely where he's gonna be you're
gonna put a grouse dragon behind this
thing it'd definitely be behind a gross
drippy door yep like weird blue acid
lake doom Turkey wants to know can
Master Hunter be played offline yes
absolutely 100% and it all scales
correctly so you can have like a fun
time still fighting and having a
challenge but you don't need to have
other people but when you do decide to
take it online that's when the game gets
really good mm-hmm
so I was asking if there's a release
date for deviljho yet they haven't said
just early spring yeah I feel like it
might be so it kind of dropped me a
little closer that's good yeah all you
gotta do is kind of run up a bit yeah
you'll be there this game is $30 I'd buy
it in a heartbeat
you know that's fair if it looks like a
game that you don't want to like jump in
at like to it to me I feel a lot of a
lot of other
well 60 is is a very fair price
especially with the amount of time spent
playing it I think so but yeah you know
on the same time awesome Street guys or
that's you're wearing the Zorro set yes
I'm wearing the Soraa set which actually
you like to look up quite a bit yeah
it's really cool don't look out for that
gross that gross bad yeah it's no good
if this game was $30 I would also buy it
but this game was $60 I'd also buy it oh
we're about to get that that cutscene
I'm ready for it here's the flash don't
you grab whole berries before you
there's some right there too like they
put them around the area oh that's just
in case yeah I got the max nice this is
also one of the cooler like set-aside
areas I think
the eye patch works pretty well with
most armored sights what it does bests
best piece of armor in the game
besides the glasses by far
it's a lot of moving
what could it be
oh it's the battery being low the real
monster you actually want to hand me
that imagine uses charged enough we
don't want anything bad to happen
no god no take take that shut you always
got to be prepared always have a cable
somewhere that you can reach the best
monster hunter is a prepared monster
hunter for all situations there they are
oh boy it's got teeth on side of its
tongue that's a little much all right
I'm going on my way you know what I'm so
confident I'm gonna use a voucher not as
big looking as yeah but oh my God look
at it dude this act this true seriously
does look like a blood-borne boss yeah
even like the mist there that is
straight out of there like the dragon
version of the blood starve beast from
hey Jack how's how's it going yeah a
little lowborn turn there alright I am
in depart on quest
probably I should not be yeah I probably
don't want to be so you notice where
your health is that oh that's me use one
of those berries so I think it's just
like a thing that happens okay I noticed
him spewing but I assume like oh I'm far
away from it I'm okay yeah hey there if
you could juice then you've got like
that constant dot that happens to which
is real fun yeah oh let's not be in here
oh shoot nope not good it's all right
you got this if you got it if you got to
walk away you know walk away a bit just
Cavalry's the Cavalry's here
we're on the way perfect good we got our
boys from last time the the crew the
whole crew is here who's here he's got a
good theme too it's pretty good all
right yes dude that that's the first
time I think I've actually seen that
like hanging all the way through yeah
that's real good real good
dual blades man one of these Monster
Hunter Mondays we should swap weapon
types and just be like how are we gonna
do hunt wise where you have a switch X
and I have monster hunter Mondays Freaky
Friday edition there you go should do
monster races and we pick each other's
weapons we have to use just like post
them up like you just give me like the
lance or something and I'm just like I
do I I'm so slow you've got to fight Val
huzzah quit the Lance and have a good
time good time
all right
[Music]
so I think hitting it stomach is a good
thing
yeah that's but it seems to be the
weakest I forgot to fill out my mega
potions whoops I only used three in the
last fight though I also did not fill
mine up yeah I'm actually how wow I'm an
idiot
oh no that's not what I want to do and
want to drop an emo so I have Auto
crafting set for potions and mega
potions I've noticed it stopped doing
that for me really yeah I'm not really
sure why like I just do it excuse me I
need to go chilling okay thankfully
still have a max potion wish you guys
have prioritized frame radiographic so
jean-luc who you're watching right now
is prioritizing frame rate and I don't
even have a pro so I can't I can't
choose that so I'm just I'm bass master
hunter I'm a basic monster I know
branches memories definitely what I
would recommend it's like I tried going
back to resolution and it looks nicer
but man if I had a pro that's what I
would yeah I launched real high up in
the air
[Music]
he's breeze fired too
I thought I saw fire clematis oh maybe
not
I mean anything is possible I know what
happened I was doing so well though all
right the Phoenix is out
that's one car it's all good he's
already moving to the next area we're
doing some damage here
mmm-hmm no he's going very slowly we
have my I don't have my no berry set to
something dang oh there's a material
over here Oh No look uh we got a ride oh
never mind shoot yeah I was already
who's Vaughn who's trying to get out but
then we're like nah dude
he left the music went away I was like
alright we're cool
akari's still here he's using it to win
it I'm gonna have to run and get healing
stuff here a bit
alright chop that tail the tail whoa
dude his stomach like texture moves it's
it's like wind or something weird stuff
that he uses to apply the debuff it's
like in his yeah that's cool so there's
no flash bombs
ooh did we forget flash bombs again I'll
grab him when I go grab my potions
that's from in a head right now that
we're being dumb yeah you're right wait
I don't think they fry too much go get
my my potions hello he seems to just be
over here so maybe not yes not it's not
too bad but the the other camp isn't too
far away so it's I'm gonna I'm gonna
grab some just because I'd like to have
some weapons keep the action and then
for you if you need to run not will will
do it can't respond you know actually
once you get back I'll trade out there
we go I like it
hey there you go to sleep now all right
CR shouldn't keep keep it real take it
easy
hunt those monsters and hope to see you
next week mm all right actually I might
be on tomorrow possibly not really so
that'll be a thing huh see what I see
[Music]
or grab some of these flash pods - all
right I'm on my way back don't be talkin
I only say bad things about the Lance
because I'm bad at the Lance and it's my
way to defend the fact that I don't know
how they work I have seen fantastic
Lance play though so I don't doubt the
very good time
[Music]
all right
I see him enemy spotted all right
swapping hit that thing you know the
second we passed each other
tagged just like that just like that
gross man okay Ryder died
hey guys doing over there get out of
there do it fast I need to move my no
berries to some place that is literally
not there just to the other end all that
beam is real bad
make a potions don't worry you still got
Bank of bomberos we're good on that I
went in I went in okay good
there it is again
he's gonna move know what damage
happened that's that's what matters
I see guys always come to me good by the
way he's on his way to you awesome Oh
perfect
what I wanted yo
by the way that beam is awful that was
really long and really gross back away
heal up excuse me good sir I need to
heal now I chew our
there it is no I was hit with that I was
I was down below it still hit me though
when I'm stunned
I'm just a way back here we're good oh
my goodness do I walked way into that I
was like you know maybe I can beat this
and worst decision also don't go in the
water the water oh yeah as a heads-up
cuz it looks like it's a good time but
it's definitely not a good time
no fish in there nice could you imagine
my dudes I've said some I'd the oneis
the dual blades I'm using the dual
blades right now it's true
the boys are a good time a lot of people
are up into that I think they sort of
this like stigma that like all dual
blades are like the easy thing oh
they're easier to understand but I mean
they're pretty cool like oh no weapon
chain don't do this to me don't do this
to me no one kid on the other side of
him up that looks like a beam yeah yep
he's in the water though huh no get out
of the water table water
oh don't want to be that guy but your
boy might need to run you get more photo
shoots already oh yeah
I've been doing some real dumb things oh
that works
my try what are we got one card right
yeah just one so far so that's good you
can play the campaign multiplayer uh yes
or no so you can play the campaign but
you have to wait for the person to
finish the cut or you can join them
which is pretty annoying just so that
technically we are playing the story
co-op right now sure but yeah Jen look
had to come and find the monster first
before I could call for help left this
is the perfect time to actually grab
things if we need to agree I think we're
over past halfway we're doing this this
is this fights happening this is it's
it's going down there just going right
for him it's cool I'll be there in a sec
not change my equipment I'm gonna do
this I'm gonna pick up these bitter bugs
hey the insect late when I first used it
and it grew on you I see a lot of people
who are picking up the insect late which
is exciting because it's not like the
most like intense weapon but it's yeah
look out for that dude I came right
around the corner and found it it was
great and sick leave is really rad
there we go tails go you betcha
pulling the cavalry cutting off that
tail oh he's gotta be he's gotta be
charging up for it
it's a real beefy charge
come back here
always running away grab that grab that
tail yeah that's that stuff that's that
good stuff
boy I didn't get a tail it's a it's a
real dead scale nope never mind doesn't
know what he wants either he's got to be
like what two-thirds web not off the
side please ah perfect
yes we broke his stomach heck yeah we
did
get up on there very nice very nice yeah
well played it's a good flash
Oh got another part
oh we're hurting in
he looks like it's kind of slow now I
got flash pods he cow me for that
yeah sir I got hit with his wing yeah
okay what's he doing get it flashed
that's what
I'll move yeah not the stun
[Music]
jump off the rock jump off the rock I
didn't jump off the rock
beep not today
we broke something else on him what
other parts left to break on this guy oh
I see oh we both tried to do the same
thing
I just couldn't touch out of the way
that's what level we're at I believe I'm
on 14 yeah I'm I'm like 29 I think you
were saying after I beat these guys
today I'm too wrinkled like shoot up
right yeah yeah laughs you beat up
Alaska last night which I need to beat
these guys to get supplies yeah Phoenix
is on him do it Phoenix ride him take
him home knock him out Yeah right
dragon paws do do more damage I don't
know what else they do but I know that
there
okay
and I was running away my running I mean
definitely limping by limping I mean
flying running man he doesn't know what
he wants to do
oh no oh thank you for that flash
whoever did that I got excited and I
shot my flash bomb no that was actually
perfect I was not gonna let not let this
dragon take you for a ride Shawn move
Wow God he's definitely been he's gotta
be I'm gonna miss every single one of my
swings broke all the bottom Jerry now
it's running out there's that limp oh
man do you think we can do it again do
it again I think I don't know if we all
have all the bombs I got to make a bomb
barrels oh okay well either way we'll
get a whole bunch of damage it'll be a
good time you just killed all the things
around us oh my god did you see that
perfect iframes perfect dodge I did it
okay quick
I mean calculated just like everything
on monster on Mondays it was entirely
calculated 100% planned
we weren't carried at all not 200%
carried hi-yah
really well oh look at that Jim OH
the beginning
how bad the the first rant run she's
just gonna let me nervous I was like oh
I don't know if this is gonna it's like
it's like running you can't just start
running you have to do stretches you
know so we had to do our our stretches
so to get ready to fight these monsters
and that's what we did and thank you
again V Phoenix and Hikari for 200%
carrying yeah that's real fun that was
real good that was good
ah whoa I do how long have we been doing
this for to eat we're at one o'clock
probably shouldn't do the last fight
then probably not I was thinking about
so that's like a that's like a 30 to 45
minute thing yeah there's a lot of
cutscenes I know with that one so let's
maybe see that for next time
nah probably not I'll probably go to
[ __ ] save that for when you sit back
down at your desk next time though we'll
definitely be doing some tempered
monsters yeah to know that you can do a
sword slash from the jump and yes I do
zoos I think I said your name how it is
it's a good time I like it Mondays we
fought them thought all three a special
shout-out to everyone who helped us out
and hung out in the lobby made is a
wonderful monster and eventually joined
our sweet clan so yeah tune back in next
Monday and we'll have even more monster
hunting probably fighting some temperate
monsters some some late-game stuff yeah
and then yeah tune back in every Monday
or not Monday sorry every day at 11:00
because we have live streams all the
time not really sure what we're gonna be
doing throughout the week so yeah I'm
sure we got some cool stuff planned you
said you might be on a stream yeah
depending on what happens to stay tuned
don't go anywhere
eleven o'clock yeah and we day I know
that I think at two o'clock we're gonna
be doing Yakuza six so make sure tuned
for that and see you guys
next time
you